hi I'm Ryan and I'm David and we're
gonna review the new Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles trailer that Michael Bay
produce he produced the movie not the
trailer it's directed by Jon Jonathan
Liebesman who did wrath of the Titans in
battle la yeah that's true David you've
been pretty excited about this trailer
my I love the old Ninja Turtles that has
animatronic suits I love my favorite
movie when I was eight years old I was
secret of use which is Ninja Turtles
part two now we've been talking about
this in the office a bit secret of the
news was my favorite as a child - I have
a revisited but I have revisited the
original the first one yeah I'll tell
you what ladies and gentlemen it holds
up it does it's a really good movie it's
it's the comics are based off of Frank
Miller's daredevil run in the 80s the
two guys Peter Laird and Kevin Eastman
we really wanted to do something similar
about ninjas and if you know much about
daredevil and there's the hand which is
why the Ninja Turtles version is called
the foot and then splinter is the mentor
and in daredevil it's stick so there's a
lot of references like that
yeah so that's sort of in the 80s that's
where it all kind of came from that's
what I think I like most about this is
sort of like gritty New York crime but
with ninjas and like ancient Japanese
culture coming into the new New York
culture and stuff like now now here we
see our first look at William Fichtner
as what will become the shredder and
Megan Fox playing April O'Neil and back
here there's obviously some ninja
imagery because shredder is ninjas
however in this version shredder is
played by a white man mm-hmm which I'm a
little disappointed with and also they
kind of established this thing that he
and April O'Neill's father created the
Turtles
yeah later we see April O'Neil with a
smart it's actually coming up right here
she's a reporter famously but we see
kind of a smartphone was using a
smartphone so we've modernized the Ninja
Turtles yeah and she's wearing a kind of
modernized version of the Yellow Jacket
green nail polish because that's what
the theme in this movie is Green Green
Green Green
we didn't know it could be a theme but
it is um we also don't see splinter
anywhere in this also tons of lens flare
now that's probably in the use from TGR
I yeah that's actually in all the design
that's changed since the first series in
this one
that's strikingly similar
um so there's eternal I think it's leave
our tire shop seen a giant sword she's
got two swords let's just talk I'm not
crazy about the turtle design and I am a
little crazy however about the design I
enjoy it I just think they should not be
so large
sir should seven feet tall and they're
like baby like three feet wide like
they're football players ninjas are
meant to be sleek more like Spider Man
esque like like skinny yeah yeah yeah
like a like a Corvette yes
which we will see later there is a tcri
they change it I think it's supposed to
be TG well David's with her maybe that
is a G I don't know
so there's our four there's like the
actual and remember us toy era Ninja
Turtles are kind of like a toys movie
and transformers was also a toys movie
that also had Megan Fox there's our
first shot of Will Arnett who's playing
the cameraman assumably a cameraman and
then if you look this is a really quick
shop but it's Donnie obviously gotta
tell them it has some vision goggles
yeah some kind of Donatello as we know
is the inventor of that's that's the
shredder costume and I like that I like
that as well that that looks like the
Shred there's only so much you could
change about the threader costume it's
like you know it's Darth Vader with a
point also speaking of changes like a
year ago there's all over the internet
everyone was buried the Ninja Turtles
would be aliens and then they finally
confirmed no that's not the case but
I've also been reading that maybe that
ooze is alien which i think is okay
because that actually is from my comics
there you go
david says okay so there's a full body
shot you lookin good kill like he's hurt
like he'd kill anyone there's a giant
like nine foot long sword so much yeah
he is taller in this shot than the
Empire State I understand perspective is
a thing so now we're in the snow we
don't know first movie they take kind of
a retreat to a lake house we're
wondering what are they - a snow house
I'd be fun um and here's like a shot of
some action there's Donatello's bow
it's very video gaming but I'm okay with
that yeah you know I mean it's
turtles I just the one thing that really
gets me is and I don't like the turtle
design at all I'm okay especially here
when when Michelangelo takes his mask
off kind of freaks me out it's like
seeing like a teacher in high school oh
we've always wore glasses and then took
them off you know and if you've seen our
behind-the-scenes pictures there's a lot
of there's motion capture so this was
probably an actor doing everything yeah
assumably
lots on his face assumedly a
seven-foot-tall actor yeah or a man on
stills um I mean let's be honest here
people I'm gonna see it yeah no one's
not gonna see it okay but I'm not crazy
about the trailer I kind of am I'm a
little worried that it took so long to
get a trailer for a movie that comes out
in August like we were seeing summer
movie trailers back in like November and
December and this is the first time
we're seeing this and they all over the
Internet the Paramount was like hiding
all the pictures because I think they
just didn't want anyone to see like they
weren't putting up much publicity yeah
so we have some years user comments it's
actually kind of pretty positive in
terms of how people are reacting I mean
some people who one person says it looks
awesome one person says Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles is going to be fun to
watch which you know is probably true
one person says terrible just terrible
but you know we'll see we'll see how it
goes
I'm gonna go everybody who loves the
Ninja Turtles no one's really gonna skip
this one we've been waiting for another
live action for years but let us know
what you think comment more below and
let us know if you're excited and and
what the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
have meant to you yeah did you like
secret of the ooze cuz that's it's a
masterpiece that's what David wants to
know on par with the 400 blows enclosing
hammers at a third time
secret of the is it is an awesome movie
anyway until next time I'm Ryan and I'm
David thank you for watching